and so it's all about showcasing the  family is very secure they all know what  role is expected of them  oh is that a police yeah looking into  the road yeah we seem to have a couple  of people interrupting administrators  yeah the parade there they've rushed  the police will be very worried about  the soldiers in this situation we've got  to remember that it's an interesting  time  in the world and people  who are of course in a democracy  encouraged to come and enjoy this or  express their views at it but we  do know that the security here because  members of the world family are coming  down shortly there will be concern to  make sure that soldiers are safe  it's a huge job isn't it for the  security services well there are  thousands of people absolutely as we  speak and they want to make sure that  this occasion is seen to be as open as  possible